natasha khan ap fontaine coup et oui
votre route dans une taie nef a vraiment
marqué l'imaginaire collectif
encore aujourd'hui on vous en parlait
comme en bien en mal an très bien je
pense que c'est jj prix j'avais pris un
grand risque très conscient toujours
voyagé un peu partout au québec et
ailleurs
et jusqu'ici je reçois vraiment beaucoup
d'amour et en fait c'est là c'est ce qui
me rassure pour tout ce que j'ai vécu
comme hank cité par rapport à ce choix
là que j'ai fait mais je voulais prouver
aussi que nous en tant qu'artiste on est
capable de porter ce qu'on nous propose
zoom si on n'est pas d'accord avec cela
si on trouve une brèche quelque part
nadal est amplifiée d'aller le porter
beaucoup plus loin et ce chaque artiste
autochtone à ce pouvoir le nom de
transfigurer ski de l'autonomie
si le territoire nous et physiquement
inaccessible
[Musique]
et si nous nous n'avons plus la force
d'y retourner
je me dis on pourrait du moins le faire
avec avec notre imaginaire vous êtes
écrivent elles pas être militante
autochtones et écologistes le monde a
fait d'ailleurs un portrait de vie vous
êtes encore tout jeune qu'est ce que
vous voulez dire à travers votre ombre
je veux toujours savoir exprimer ce que
le peuple pense tout leur sens j'ai
toujours conçu que ce que je ressens on
pourrait être en harmonie avec ce que le
ce que le peuple ressent vraiment donc
moi j'ai toujours je me suis toujours
perçue comme une interprète
si la prochaine génération parle pas sa
langue si on si on se dit pourquoi est
ce que ce serait important qu'ils
gardent leur langue aux autres plus tard
ils seront pas pourquoi ils sont là
c'est pourquoi il existe pourquoi ils
sont en vie parfois je prends la liberté
de m'exprimer - mais souvent quand
j'écris c'est pas seulement pour moi
c'est pour la collectivité et je pense
que c'est le rôle du poète en grande
majorité le magnifique film documentaire
qui va être dans les cinémas la fin
d'année qui va être présenté à présence
autochtone très bientôt ça s'intitule
mines et époux yann mon cri quel est
votre cri natasha khan ap photo je pense
mon cri c'est vraiment celui
avoir le droit d'exister sur son
territoire et de pouvoir vivre en
relation et ce territoire au utah au
comité de lightman de just begun to
speak kleynhoff inhumaines street french
donc vivre mon identité innu au
quotidien sans entrave
même si la société d'aujourd'hui
mais beaucoup dans des clans dans ce
parcours là dans ce processus le mais
justement mon processus est de trouver
les moyens de vivre une identité quand
même au milieu de cette structure le
coin le stf coin de la poésie m'offre du
cou à cette possibilité de la création
différents mais une expression le
théâtre la scène la prise de parole meuf
beaucoup c'est possible
nous reconstruirons par mais moi qui lis
par pilier nos maisons en bo2 bourse le
gouvernement différents organismes
culturels injecté beaucoup d'argent pour
venir en aide aux productions autochtone
où vous situez je pense que c'est il
faut simplement trouver l'équilibré dans
le nom ce rattrapage le ne pas trop en
faire parce que justement c'est ce sera
preuve qu'il y ait peut-être un manque
de sincérité et un manque de savoir
calculer jusqu'où on peut vraiment
prouver qu'on est prêts on soutient
vraiment les autochtones donc il y à il
ya un équilibre à aller chercher
pourquoi justement secret dans le pied
une cérémonie qui est très forte en fait
je trouve
parce que elle nous rappelle à tous ont
fait que nous avons tous été en fin mai
pour louhans vont en profiter parce que
justement on a eu
a vécu beaucoup de sens ce au travers
des siècles au travers des dernières
décennies de privation de notre propre
expression une interdiction de vivre mon
cérémonie nos traditions mais aussi
novare et aujourd'hui je pense à tous
les artistes doivent en profiter
on ne sait jamais 2 mais qu'est ce qui
va arriver donc on va prendre la place
je profite de cette entrevue pour poser
la question suivante quel est le plus
grand mythe qu'on devrait être défaire
celui qui n'existaient pas et encore
beaucoup de gens qui savent pas qu'on
existe et je pense que c'est le celui
qui nous fait le plus de mal et après je
pense qu'on va pouvoir
allez dans les dialogues d'attaché
canapé de fontaine china coût 8 m à ce
que je dis comme une fonte des neiges
comme et m
[Musique]
le peuple a
devenez